you're looking live at capitol hill
where the biggest names in tech are
still
on the hot seat they've been there all
afternoon the ceos of apple google
facebook and amazon
getting grilled during an anti-trust
hearing but earlier republicans went
after the executives
over allegations of conservatives being
censored on social media
i'll just cut to the chase big text out
to get conservatives
that's not a suspicion that's not a
hunch that's a fact
if i had a nickel for every time i heard
it was just a glitch
i wouldn't be as wealthy as our
witnesses but i'd be doing all right
conservatives are consumers too
and the way the net was put together in
the eyes of congress
is that everybody should be able to
speak their mind
and can you today assure americans you
will not tailor your features in any way
to help specifically help one candidate
over other and this
this what i'm concerned about is you're
helping joe biden over president trump
we won't do any work uh you know it to
politically tilt anything one way or the
other it's against our core values
all right the ceos denied any bias so
another day another hearing let me go to
you jesse
um i don't know if you got a chance to
see much of that today but
you know anytime we have hearings on
capitol hill about tech
you just kind of want to cringe
through the questions that are being
asked because many times you realize
that the members they have an idea of
what they're talking about but they're
not well versed
in the technology they don't know the
difference between instagram facebook
twitter
nothing they're worse than i am i i do
have to give credit where credit is due
dana because the democrats have done
something very smart and i it really
pains me to say that
they've launched this campaign in
silicon valley for these tech giants to
root out
hate speech and misinformation but the
democrats in dc
agree with the democrats in silicon
valley that
hate speech and misinformation only
comes from
conservatives because so what hate
speech is basically anything
that offends a democrat and
misinformation is anything a democrat
disagrees with so these pc police types
and
and the fact checkers of the mainstream
media get on these
platforms and they build these speech
walls against conservative speech
and these walls keep closing in yet the
democrats
they can talk about misinformation all
day long like the
russia hoax and they can pay no price
they can slander conservatives all day
long call them white supremacists
rapists they can plan riots on social
media they don't pay a price
so it's unfair and the democrats say you
better do this
censor conservatives to these tech
giants or we'll break up your monopolies
for them with money
they pay everybody off and they have all
their lobbyists take everybody on quail
hunts
and to fancy dinners because all they
know is that once a year they come up
bend over get spanked and then they walk
back to their desks and make a billion
dollars a day and nothing changes
all right so um one of those people that
is under the
um gun from democrats is mark zuckerberg
of facebook
um and juan take a listen to what he
said come very consistent with what he
told us
a month or so ago when we did an
interview with him about
this uh issue of the democrats wanting
facebook to take down all sorts of
things including basically
trump's uh twitter feed or facebook feed
take a listen our goal is to
offer a platform for all ideas we've
distinguished ourselves as one of the
the companies that defends free
expression the most
we do not uh want to become the arbiters
of of truth
i think that that would be um a bad
position for us to be in and not
uh not what we should be doing
why can't the democrats seem to think
that that's
okay juan to to say that you want to be
neutral
on a platform
i think it's all right with everybody i
think the real issue going back to what
jesse was saying
has to do with uh you know propaganda
lies
hate speech that kind of thing but uh
you know i think today
just to pick up again on what jesse was
saying i
i saw samson brenner asking zuckerberg
about twitter like he thought zuckerberg
ran twitter he doesn't even know the
difference apparently
so i i i get i get the idea that
really watching this it looked like
republicans
you know how you guys said the democrats
weren't allowing barr to speak yesterday
so today it's republicans not allowing
any of these tech executives to speak
and basically working the ref saying hey
we don't like it when you limit
uh you know don jr when he's putting
stuff out there
or we don't like it at all so okay i
mean i guess that's their message
but to me this was supposed to be an
anti-trust hearing
and you know to the point of who's got
more political leverage
i think right now president trump and
his administration have done nothing in
terms of
promoting competition on the high-tech
sector
there's more of a threat to those
high-tech bosses from the prospect
i'll just finish up it's more more of a
threat i think
from a joe biden and a democratic
uh congress in terms of actually putting
in place
legislation and passing it that would
reign in
and these monopolies and allow real
competition allow the little guy to get
in the game so
if that's the issue then i think the
political leverage is more on the right
but greg thinking about this you know
the free market system and here you have
these four
tech ceos american companies employing
lots of americans and and also having a
global presence
and you have this these guys saying that
big government
should be would be better at running
making decisions for these companies
than the free market
yeah it's uh it
when you look at these hearings in
general it's why i didn't even watch
this hearing today because i was hearing
out i took all of my self-control not to
drive to dc
and tp the capital whenever you take any
issue
whether it's justice or it's the
internet
hearings are an intellect removal
machine
it's like it replaces brains with
outrage theater and i don't think
you never get to the bottom of anything
you just go back to the top
we are participating in an experiment
with social media it affects all of our
lives
it's only going to get bigger and
ubiquitous and more powerful
so the question for conservative is
conservatives are do you want it to
become the fourth
horseman of the left you know they the
left won
when it comes to culture they have the
entertainment industry they have media
they have academia
so we have this fourth thing it's social
media it's the social media platform
do you want to just hand it over without
a fight because once you hand it over it
never comes back
and we know that with academia there's
never academia is purely
left and you know the media will never
be conservative
none of these things will change and by
the way to jesse's point
uh i want to back it up it's not about
hate speech
it's about the accusation of hate speech
which is used to silence you and damage
your career and this is happening
everywhere not just social media
yeah katie one thing i thought that you
know i didn't hear too much about it
today but
the trump administration has gone to bat
for these american companies especially
overseas when you have
um governments like in the eu for
example that want to heavily tax or
regulate or change
these companies they've gone to bat for
them would a biden administration do the
same
i think it depends you know there's not
a lot in washington d.c
that both sides of the political aisle
agree on and they still disagree but the
one thing they do agree on is that big
tech there are problems on both sides
jim jordan today was very adamant about
pointing out
issues of bias that have been alleged
against these big tech companies and the
double standard that does exist when it
comes to
free speech on their platforms and i
have to say you know mark zuckerberg
says we're not gonna
regulate speech or be the arbiters of
truth but they actually kind of
they cop out because they hire quote
fact checkers from like the associated
press or the new york times
that are left-leaning publications to do
the fact-checking for them
and then those posts are then flagged
and the pages that they're on are
flagged and they're limited in terms of
their view
so this idea that they don't actually
regulate what goes on
on their platforms isn't necessarily
true but i also don't know a big
government
is the way to fix this especially
considering
how today went and they always think
that they're better than everyone that
they're smarter than their witnesses
today was a show of that is not
necessarily true
not true all right